winning a World Series was I mean it's
an it's obviously a the highest goal for
any baseball team but winning a World
Series for that city after all they've
been through meant a great deal yeah
absolutely you know uh right when I got
traded Harvey had just happened I mean
to the point where we couldn't get in
the airport the airport was still closed
the day after the trade so to be able to
come in and experience how that city
rallied around us as a team and really
you know for us to be able to give
people that were going through a hard
time something too something to cheer
for and-and-and a reprieve from whatever
they were struggling with at the time
you know I felt a real connection with
them and I felt it back you know I threw
my charity wins for warriors I donated
some money when I first got there and
then I decided to donate my playoff
share as well so it's added up to over
half a million dollars for you it is a
funny thing it is a funny thing how in
the right situations when when the chips
are really down I'm a from Boston so I
grew up and I'm a Boston Red Sox fan
that's where I grew up
and when they went through the Marathon
bombing that was you could tell there
was some something happened to the team
and the city where they've sort of came
together it's very strange but sports
can do that people can sort of when
they're down and out they sometimes put
their hope and their their dreams and
their aspirations into a sports team and
it almost feels like it helped fuel you
guys a little bit absolutely you know we
we thrived on that I mean it was kind of
just like it was meant to be and that's
kind of how we felt about everything
even when in the championship series we
went down we were going back to Houston
and we were down two games we had to win
the next two or we were eliminated
nobody panicked it was just kind of like
this this this script has already been
written like we're supposed to win
that's really what it felt like and and
everybody really believed that
you